you and Jah obviously have been in the
league five years now same draft class
you know both from South Carolina how
disappointing is it to not get to face
him
again uh I mean it's unfortunate uh I
always like competing against J uh
that's my brother we go back since them
SC days
and I mean knowing J he gonna come back
to the court better than
ever and I know obviously like you said
he's going through his struggles right
now but um the kid you played a with
back in the day what do you recall about
him off the court what was that guy
like I
[Music]
mean the kid back then and then the the
man now uh both of them both of them are
great dudes uh I don't have anything
negative to say about J I never will
that's my brother I mean we all live and
we learn and I can't wait to see him
back on the court